sternstunden parlamentsarbeit mit serdar
somuncu
ganz deutschland legt sich furchtbar auf
dabei hat die afg doch nur was gefragt
wer nicht fragt bleibt dumm
deswegen hat die afg um nichtstun zu
bleiben
in einer kleinen anfrage an die groko
einfach mal unverbindlich wissen wollen
zitat wie hat sich nach kenntnis der
bundesregierung die zahl der behinderten
seit 2012 entwickelt insbesondere die
durch heirat innerhalb der familien
standen und wie viele fälle haben einen
migrationshintergrund ja entschuldigung
man muss doch wissen wie viele von den
behinderten behindert sind weil der
kemal seine cousine geknackt hat ist das
jetzt schon rassismus ich meine ja so
ist sie halt die alternative gibt ihnen
irgendein problem schuld sind die
ausländer sagen wir mal fehlende
öffentliche verkehrsmittel im ländlichen
raum bürger stinksauer weil weil die
arme rentnerin aus dem bayerischen wald
zurecht sauer ist wenn sie auf den bus
warten muss der dreimal am tag kommt
während die asylbewerber nebenan auf
staatskosten mit dem taxi abgeholt
werden
tja so ist es doch deutschen omas brennt
die milch an während direkt nebenan
asylbewerber in einer goldenen sänfte
zum himmel metzger getragen werden oder
beispiel klimawandel haben auch die
flüchtlinge verbockt die merkel lässt
die hier rein obwohl obwohl ein co2
abdruck eines mitteleuropäers zehnmal so
groß ist wie eines menschen in afrika
das heißt eine million menschen die sie
zu uns holen wir brauchen oder erzeugen
zehnmal so viel co2 wie in afrika eben
wenn die flüchtlinge die schweren könnte
ich weiter mit meinem suv zum bioladen
brettern
mut mache ich sowieso aber das ist ja
nicht das thema
ich habe auch mal ein zwei kleine
anfragen
ich möchte von der regierung wissen wie
viel offen lesbisch lebender afd
vorsitzende die mit einer ausländerin
verpartnert sind haben schon mal
schwarzen eine putzfrau beschäftigt und
wie viel davon leben in der schweiz und
hat mich einfach mal passiert ist
wie ist eigentlich die inzucht situation
im deutschen adel ist da der genpool
wirklich noch im grünen bereich
hallo ich frag doch nur scheiß political
correctness sternstunden deutsche
parlament arbeitet
[Musik]
serdar somuncu
[Applaus]